give me every choice you are about to
die the hands of the children of Thanos
be thankful that your meaningless lives
now is closed today
you better pack it up and get out of
here
stem Kiba does this chattering animals
speak for you
certainly not I speak for myself
trespassing in this city and on this
planet that's right in a while good to
have you buddy where's your gun I don't
know is everybody having a thing it's no
time for a thing you know that's the
thing right there let's go
[Music]
dude reimbursing me from the Wizards III
can't do a wall I don't think stand down
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie earth is
closed today you may have heard about
the Captain Marvel Easter Egg hiding in
plain sight during this big battle that
most people didn't really pay attention
to just because we weren't thinking
about it when you think about Captain
Marvel after this movie it's mostly just
that post credit scene because that's a
direct reference to here this is a
message to Captain Marvel get your ass
to earth and help us there are a couple
news sites that are mistaken about
what's going on during this - and what
it is that the filmmakers are trying to
do with this so I'll explain no worries
if you're brand new to the channel
there's a new round of that infinity war
blu-ray giveaway since I forgot to name
a winner in my last video I'll name two
winners at the end of this but in this
scene when they're fighting them for the
time stone at the sanctum you see Cole
obsidian walk up wearing a very bright
red sash with gold bands on it that
looks mysteriously like Captain Marvel's
classic red and blue comic book costume
so people like wait a minute what's
going on here she's wearing the green
costume during most of the Captain
Marvel movie we know that she's gonna be
wearing the classic red and blue costume
because of all the concept art that
we've seen during Avengers 4 but the
thing about this is that it's not her
comic book sash is a little bit
different it just made to look like hers
and he ends up getting dusted in that
bug-zapper of a shield and Wakanda at
the end of the movie anyway so any sash
that he would have been wearing would
have been vaporized
[Music]
this is just one of those situations
where the people that make the movie the
costume designers are just having a
little bit of fun with comic books up
because Kol obsidian this character does
not wear a sash in the comics so at some
point in the development process when
they were doing special effects for all
this motion capture somebody spent a ton
of hours making this look very much like
Captain Marvel sash so it was a very
conscious choice it's not like somebody
accidentally just put it on him there's
all kinds of Easter eggs like that in
the background that the directors
sometimes don't even know about just
because there's so much stuff going on
and these sets are so big so like a
little while ago there was a comic book
artist at Marvel that got fired for
putting religious messages into the
comic books Marvel books go through
several different steps of quality
control
so if weird religious messages can make
it into books that go to print to
millions of people around the world
without Marvel heads knowing about it
it's pretty easy for design elements and
background things like this and little
Easter eggs to make it in without
everybody being aware of what's going on
just because it's such a huge huge
project another really good example of
that is them using music cues from
previous movies so when Tony was telling
pepper like yeah I'm not gonna make it
back hun they played the exact same
music cue that they played when Captain
America when he was crashing the plane
in the ocean
saying goodbye to Peggy yeah I'm not
gonna make it back be sure to save that
dance for me what's going on yeah I'm
fine I just think we might have to push
our a three rows by just cuz I'll
probably make it back for a while
tell me you're not on that show yeah I'm
sorry I don't know
[Music]
thank you
you're gonna need a rain check on that
dance so it's not like they're saying
coal obsidian at some point has run into
Captain Marvel and taken her sash or
anything like that they're not old
enough to have run into Captain Marvel
20-plus years ago now Thanos is
extremely long-lived
some of the black order are older than
others like he picks up his children
quote-unquote as he goes along and
conquers worlds remember when we were on
gomorrah's planet you see all the
shatori in the background because that
was when he was still going planet to
plant it the slow style erasing half the
population you see a beanie ma
who looks just as old as he is in
present day saying the exact same thing
in the events leading up to this movie
they did take downs and are in the Nova
Empire to get the Power Stone so at some
point when they were going around space
just erasing half of all life on all
these worlds all these years he could
have taken it off the costume of another
Kree warrior but that person would not
have been Captain Marvel 1 because she's
gonna be super powerful by the end of
the Captain Marvel movie and 2 it really
does sound like there's gonna be some
time-travel involved to explain how it
is that she still looks like she's in
her 20s
even though Avengers 4 is happening
20-plus years after the events of her
movie so at no point would they have run
into each other now we actually don't
even know if she's gonna be wearing the
sash during Avengers 4 because the
concept art makes it look like she's not
going to be she might just be wearing it
during the Captain Marvel movie has a
sort of wink at the classic Miss Marvel
costume from the comics but she's worn
several different versions and she
didn't even start out wearing the sash
so originally she had this version of
the costume there was a red cape with
like an open stomach area the second
version of the costume just covered up
that stomach piece but it was the same
basic costume then she got what most
people remember as the Miss Marvel
costume the black one with the lightning
bolt down the middle that's when she
started wearing the red sash so it's
almost like they just moved the cloth of
the cape down to her waist
it was around 2012 when she became the
Captain Marvel that we'll see her as
during the movie she was Miss Marvel for
pretty much most of comic book history
then during an adventure with Captain
America she had become a captain in the
Air Force so Captain America was like
you know what you should start calling
yourself Captain Marvel instead of Miss
Marvel so it was based on his suggestion
the thing about the movie version of the
costume is is that she did wear
Green Creek costume in the comics for a
little while when she was with Marvel
the really cool Easter Egg buried in
this is that if you invert the colors
you get the classic red blue comic book
costume but hopefully that explains
what's going on with this sash like it's
an easter egg but it's not exactly what
people think there's just a lot of new
sites that are like he's wearing Captain
Marvel sash and no like that's not
exactly what's going on they just want
you to think about Captain Marvel like
oh wow he's wearing a sash like Captain
Marvel that looks a lot like Captain
Marvel's congratulations to the latest
giveaway winners from my last big Marvel
videos Miguel Ramirez and Craven fan
please email me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details click here to learn all about
which characters are crossing over from
Avengers 4 to Spider Man far from home
and click here for that deleted Deadpool
x-men scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]